[Music]
[Applause]
happy holidays everyone this time of
celebration comes once a year
so do our awesome new holiday items of
course
you made sure to be good all year round
make sure you save some bucks to get
yourself the gift
that you most surely deserve make it to
the top of the leaderboards and you'll
get some gold
frankincense and mirror or their in-game
equivalent
and may your winter be as fun as winter
can be
[Music]
what's up my fellow gamers it's gaming
month hallelujah
and you know what the best form of
gaming is game show
we all know we all know it it's
everyone's favorite
my favorite is when they answer really
stupid and and i can go
that's the dumbest [ __ ] i ever heard so
that's what we're doing today
miners and hoes
[Laughter]
what oh god miners and hoes
what a freudian slip right there bruh
put that man into jail
winners are losers everyone's oh wait oh
no
it doesn't work winners and foes not
hoes
what's the answer oh god maybe it was
right
miners and hoes
starts he's talking about minecraft it's
a gaming
month reference mining and home yeah
a group of pill pushers a group
of pill pushers
that's not that bad i don't get it what
was wrong with a group of pill pushers
i do it all the time it's worth a
thousand dollars
greg uh an ace of kidneys ace of kidneys
i believe that's an ace of kidneys an
act of kindness you dumbass
george here this term for a long-handled
gardening tool
can also mean an immoral pleasure seeker
ho
ho ho it's a migraine reference cam
what's a hoe
no
what do you mean whoa
whoa what do you mean
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
do not judge ken these [ __ ] got
minus
he's got 14 000. i think what ken says
is correct
it's a goddamn hoe they teach you that
in school in utah huh al
what's a rake a rake is right rake
[ __ ] wreck was stupid in it it's a
hoe
what oh is the generic word for any
living animal or plant including
bacteria and viruses
organism orgasm
[Laughter]
dumb eh close enough he's a gamer you
can tell
how is hoe not the right answer okay i'm
not the only one and i never heard
someone
being referred yeah rake vehicles
are used to compete in the legendary
tour de france
bicycle uh suvs
[Music]
yes amazing a specific part of the body
that women
try to accentuate
ass
[Laughter]
well done name a part of the body that
gets bigger as adults get older
i'm not i'm not answering that freddy
penis
look at freddy's good smile
it's almost as cringey as at the 30 year
old saying peepee online
name a kind of bear
papa
[Music]
i love this so funny a papa bear
you know the breed of papa bear normally
worn only
by children michael
clothes
something where only my children i like
they that's the thing they press
just so they can be first and then
hoping that they'll come up with an
answer and then they end up
close something only children wear um
those badass hats with the propeller on
top
i never got it i want to wear it diapers
and something you might accidentally
leave on all night
your shoes
[Laughter]
oh how do you accidentally don't take
this the wrong way can it but
you are weird
[Laughter]
got a boyfriend i'm sorry
[Applause]
i was just trying to get off the subject
of schools i'm sorry michael i forg
forgive me a girlfriend have you got a
girlfriend
no i'm gay
i'm so sorry for accidentally
oh man that was not a bad show answer
that was doing more than epic game of
moment name something you feel before
you buy it
yeah what will you guys say ah you feel
before you bite melons
you gotta knock them excited
[Laughter]
well he's not wrong he's not wrong he's
not wrong
i live in orange county i'm [ __ ] i
mean retired
[Applause]
poor lady luckily she's probably dead
now otherwise she'd be canceled on
twitter
what country has the highest ratio of
doctors to population
the country with the most jews
i would say israel you have a doctor in
every family it's a cousin could be an
uncle a plus specialist
i'll agree you agree with that
it's israel
what the [ __ ] what should you do about a
hairy back
uh i usually close my eyes and imagine
she's wearing an alpacas
oh come on i want dumb answers okay yeah
i want who wants to be a millionaire
yeah yeah yeah 50 50
as the audience about a friend it's all
here for you
so if you're and here's the deal you can
only laugh
if you knew the answer ready let's play
who wants to be
a millionaire according to the nursery
rhyme what did a little jack horner pull
from a pie
i have no [ __ ] clue we have different
lyrics in sweden i don't know
okay let me guess it plumb black bird
little jill horner okay everyone laughed
on little jitter horn i don't think he's
a little gentle harder
well he didn't pull a blackbird or a
ribbon so it's got to be a plug
right well regis i was kind of afraid of
nursery rhymes there's
early questions here but i think i know
this one
um i'm gonna say
blem c blackbird
you know it's kind of intense isn't it
for a hundred dollars really it is you
know it's not like anybody's watching
yeah
you idiot you fool so your final answer
is
um
bro you're talking about pulling a dead
bird out of a pie
as a nursery rhyme you [ __ ] [ __ ]
final answer is c blackbird he says
blackbird
my gosh it was a plum
brian i'm sorry
you are stupid anyway brian
it was a plum yeah sometimes those
things are a little obscure in your
memory
but uh something about four and 20
blackbirds baked in a pie was in my head
right it's too late it's over i know
nice try and good luck to you and uh
i'm sorry zero
enjoy nothing when attacked by predators
which of these animals will often
activate a large gland known as
cheetahs cheetah perry's health
owl c oh she was quick to owls
i'm so sorry you knew after you said it
lovey i am so sorry
what the [ __ ] did you say owl what do
you mean large glenn
how does that
you know what i'm not going out in the
first question don't uh you're not going
out on the first question all right
we'll see this
it's llamas i'll play it's a minecraft
reference i'm gonna take the 50 50 here
i'm a little i'm a little sure but let's
see what happens 50 50. all right throw
up the computer please take away two of
them
let me guess chihuahua and the correct
one of course
yeah elephants or lemons
okay that was the one i thought so i'm
going to go with
sea llamas wait that's wrong
see lamas final answer that's my answer
final answer it was elephant really
i guess i'm done homeowners buy surge
protectors to protect
their possessions from unexpected surges
of what
electric current water flow air pressure
buyer's remorse
i will say b water flow final answer
good job oh no oh
no saddest flute for you so
sorry oh sorry
darn it dumbass they really do them
dirty with their total price money
zero they just like why
how many u.s states have names that
begin with the word
new four i think i'm going to use my
double dip on this one
okay we're going to stop the clock with
11 seconds
b
[Music]
final answer ed you can't walk away with
double dip
oh yeah with double dip you're not
allowed to walk away that's why
that's why i said if you got both wrong
you would go down get a thousand dollars
hey
i would have made it
i'm smarter bigger brain i don't know i
just guess
four it makes sense new york new jersey
new hampshire new mexico
are these states i don't know
but yeah so dumb
oh god what a meme picture what part of
speech are usually classified as being
in the active voice or passive voice i
never heard of that expression
active or passive that must be
yeah it must be verbs right
do you have that expression in school
own own
he's using all his lifelines every
single one of them
[Applause]
300 questions
he's going out old blasting it's me
no what are you doing
[Applause]
[Music]
was he trolling what the hell was that
oh man i love this
i want more i need more christy in uk
geography the road called waffling
street that now forms part of the a5 was
originally built by which civilization
eighth the romans the ladies
the monkeys the monkeys build this roads
the civilizations of their monkeys
yes apes they invented it
all oh dumbest blonde ever world
geography question
is is earth a country hungary
it's maine it's an instrument name
something people take with them to the
beach
turkey
in a supermarket turkey turkey
the food often stuffed
it's turkey it's all turkey name a
yellow fruit
[Laughter]
orange
orange dumbass this is why i'm a gamer i
would never get this wrong i get every
answer right
yeah happy gaming month see you tomorrow
look at the graph
the graph make no sense it's 101
youtube what the flip dude
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing
it's beautiful now as a popular demand
this thing now works with pc games top
pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom gotta try
this baby on doom
pub g valorent you name me
okay we don't have every game but a ton
of games so the blaster now works with
geforce now which is very cool
it also works with pc it has a ton of
library of android games
it's just a new way to play we're
bringing it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get ten dollars
off if you enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out